[Musique]
le département des alpes-maritimes a
subi un choc terrible
la montagne des alpes-maritimes a été
touché au coeur les villages de nos
vallées 1 subi un véritable traumatisme
et nous avons besoin de vous nous avons
besoin de cette solidarité et nous
lançons cet appel à l'engagement de la
nation pour ces communes monsieur le
ministre
entre le discours du président de la
république et les actes il y as souvent
hélas un écart et parfois même un fossé
la défense de la laïcité des lois de la
république est un combat fondamental qui
nous interdit de terre et de nier la
réalité de la menace islamiste sur ce
sujet les tergiversations et le en même
temps peuvent être des poisons pour les
français
aujourd'hui la prison est devenue à
l'intérieur un accélérateur de
radicalisation et à l'extérieur un
diffuseur de séparatisme 500 détenus le
sont pour des faits en lien avec le
terrorisme islamiste
1500 autres de droit commun sont connus
comme radicaliser selon l'excellent
rapport de mon collègue eric diard et
ses propositions concrètes
autant de menaces en puissance pour les
autres détenus et pour le reste de la
société
quand ils ressortiront ce n'est pas aux
éleveurs de modifier leur façon de
travailler et de s'adapter aux
comportements des loups pas plus qu'ils
n'ont à construire des bunkers pour
abriter leurs moutons au nom d'une
biodiversité y réfléchit imposées par
l'état le défi est immense
condamné plus vite faire exécuter toutes
les peines
construire des places de prisons
manquantes rénover les plus indignes
d'entre elles lutter contre la
radicalisation en milieu carcéral
traiter enfin les problèmes
psychiatriques de nombreux détenus
développer les peines alternatives miser
sur la réinsertion pour limiter les
récidives augmenter les moyens de la
production du 10 hier de la jeunesse et
enfin assurer une place une juste place
aux victimes d'un autre système
judiciaire quels pouvoirs et moyens
allez vous donner au maire
déterminé à agir qui vous sollicitent
car ils sont confrontés chaque jour à
des actes qui mettent à mal lors de
républicains l'état ne pourra se faire
respecter
que si vous exprimer devant nous
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
miné de l'intérieur
la fermeté fermeté dans l'action fermeté
dans la répression fermeté dans la
sanction
il en va de la venue de l'avenir de la
france la plus grande entreprise de
france souffre vous la connaissez nous
la connaissons tous
ce sont nos artisans de commerçants et
pme ainsi que certaines professions
libérales qui sont au coeur du
développement économique de notre
territoire avec les députés les
républicains nous demandons depuis des
mois des annulations de charges beaucoup
plus massive pour les tpe et les pme
cela doit être la priorité dans vos
choix de dépenses publiques
sans ces annulations de charge vous
préparez des dépôts de bilan et des
faillites en cascade
[Musique]